et notre invité et réclachance président
et chef de la direction d'énergie
bonsoir Monsieur la chance alors pour
préciser d'entrée de jeu quand on parle
de gaz naturel renouvelable on fait
référence à quoi précisément
qu'elle se décompose ben elle va émettre
des gaz dans du méthane qui va aller à
l'atmosphère donc quand on fait du gaz
naturel renouvelable ce qu'on vient
faire c'est qu'on vient contrôler cette
décomposition là dans le cas du du
génère agricole on le fait avec une
usine dans le fond on amène la matière
résiduelle en guerre organique dans le
fondant cet usine là et là dans le fond
on vient capturer ce méthane là et c'est
comme ça qu'on fait du gaz renouvelable
bon c'est une annonce importante
évidemment pour énergie pour
une société de gaz naturel qui veut
réduire son empreinte environnementale
également qu'est-ce que c'est 10
installations de biométhanisation vont
vous permettre d'accomplir ça nous
permet d'accélérer vraiment la teinte de
notre objectif de 10% d'ici 20 000 30
c'est 30% de cet objectif là donc c'est
vraiment une accélérateur c'est tentant
vous avez décidé de vous associer à une
entreprise danoise de gaz naturel nature
energy qui va d'ailleurs être racheté
par Shell si je ne m'abuse il y a eu une
offre d'achat il y a quelques semaines
pourquoi ce partenariat monsieur
Lachance afin d'accélérer on veut se
donner les meilleures chances de succès
le GNR ça fait déjà plusieurs années que
dans le fond aussi intéresse qu'on le
développe et dans le secteur agricole
cette compagnie là dans le fond a déjà
14 projets en opération donc on va
vraiment chercher une expertise dans la
conception mais aussi dans l'opération
bref on vient minimiser nos risques et
accélérer le développement
actionnaire on a plus d'influence aussi
donc être à la table donc c'est un
partenariat économique également donc
oui effectivement c'est intéressant de
ce côté-là bon on a beaucoup parlé
monsieur Lachance évidemment de la
décarbonation au Québec en plus cette
semaine avec la COP15 on parle beaucoup
d'environnement de biodiversité
l'électrification des transports est à
nos portes est-ce que vous croyez que
énergir peut jouer un rôle dans la
transition énergétique de la province
certainement en fait ça fait déjà
plusieurs années qu''énergir ce
transforme on a plusieurs initiatives
qui s'inscrivent avec cette
décarbonation là
l'investissement qu'on a annoncé
aujourd'hui l'entente de partenariat
avec nature c'est un seuila donc on a
plusieurs solutions que ce soit au
niveau du GNR qui en est une mais on
travaille vraiment conjointement à
l'atteinte de la bicarbonation
de gaz naturel renouvelables dans votre
réseau donc 99% de gaz naturel qui est
issu d'énergie fossile dont l'extraction
n'a pas un bilan zéro évidemment alors
expliquez-nous comment le gaz naturel
est une solution pour la décarbonation
du Québec en fait c'est pas le gaz
naturel facile qui est une solution pour
la décarbonation c'est vraiment le
réseau qui lui a mesure que les volumes
diminuent dans le gaz naturel ce qui est
tout à fait normal puis notre plan est
aligné là-dessus euh il y a des endroits
où il est complémentaires avec
l'électricité et à travers des gaz
renouvelables ben en fait peut permettre
de le faire un meilleur coup et il y a
d'autres endroits où ça va être
technologique ou en fait l'électricité
ne sera pas aussi bien faire et c'est là
qu'on peut venir compléter en utilisant
nos infrastructures qui sont déjà là 10%
de gaz naturel renouvelable dans votre
réseau d'ici 2030 est-ce que c'est
réaliste et est-ce que c'est suffisant
est-ce qu'on pourrait aller au-delà de
cette cible là c'est clair que nous
notre souhait ce serait d'aller plus
loin que ça mais ça 10% là en fait ce
basent vraiment sur ce qu'on appelle du
génère de première génération c'est
d'enfouissement agricole et d'une
dépuration pardon donc je voudrais
crédible ce 10% là d'accord cela dit
est-ce que est-ce que les clients en
veulent parce que là en ce moment
comment ça fonctionne expliquer nous là
dans le réseau vous en avez du gaz
naturel renouvelable et c'est à la
demande que vous le distribuez comment
ça fonctionne
de favoriser les gens qui étaient prêts
à l'acheter directement le GNR plutôt
que de le mélanger un peu comme
l'éthanol dans l'essence ici on a une
clientèle qui est désireuse évidemment
c'est là c'est la poule on lance un
produit on veut s'assurer d'en avoir
assez en inventaire donc c'est après un
certain temps avant que on ouvre les
valves la commercialisation mais depuis
mai vraiment on fait de la
commercialisation en grande échelle et
ça se passe très bien oui ça se passe
bien parce qu'on avait des nouvelles un
petit peu plus tôt cette année on disait
qu'hier avait eu de la difficulté à
trouver preneur pour à peu près 55
millions de mètres cubes de gaz naturel
renouvelable qui avait été acquis pour
2021 2022 est-ce que la demande va être
au rendez-vous parce que là vous allez
en produire pas mal plus on est confiant
que la demande va être les échos depuis
qu'on a ouvert sont très positifs très
bien il y a quand même je le dis
monsieur la chance dans par exemple à
Montréal on dit souhaiter et que d'ici
un certain échéancier on refuse que les
nouveaux bâtiments soient chauffés au
gaz naturel est-ce que est-ce que ça
vaut encore la peine d'investir autant
où on devrait progressivement
diversifier du gaz naturel on est
d'accord que le bâtiment va devoir se
décarboner puis ça fait déjà plusieurs
années qu'on dit que notre stratégie
amène des solutions pour le faire comme
je dis aussi ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on se diversifie déjà aujourd'hui
énergistre une compagnie qui est
présente à presque 50 % dans ses
activités au niveau de l'électricité la
production de GNR c'est une autre
opportunité de se diversifier en
s'inscrivant parfaitement dans la
transition énergétique mais on a une
portefeuille de solution qui ne sont pas
juste gazeuses afin justement de
participer puis d'accélérer ce mouvement
là de la décarbonation ce que vous
annoncez aujourd'hui un milliard de
dollars 10 installations d'ici 2030
est-ce que c'est une première étape
est-ce qu'il y en aura d'autres par la
suite
récepteur
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]